a new amendment to hong kong's
immigration law takes effect
today critics say the change could give
the government power to ban residents
from leaving the city
hong kong's administrators say the law
part of china's crackdown on hong kong
targets illegal refugees but it has
prompted a growing exodus
the united kingdom canada and australia
are offering
extended work and residency permits to
those who've left hong kong and the u.s
congress is debating a bill to give
special visas and refugee status
to hong kong citizens fleeing political
persecution
for more on this let's cross over to dw
correspondent phoebe kong
in hong kong phoebe why is this new
immigration law
so worrying
well the new immigration law kicks in
today in hong kong that
raises concerns by the activists
lawyers and also diplomats and from the
international community as well
that the fear that the concerns that
the new law will give what they fear as
unlimited powers to the authorities
to bar people from leaving and also
entering
the chinese ruled city hong kong and
that
is a very like a big amendment to this
law but law was passed in this april
uh this april with little public
consultation and debate
uh following a collective resonation of
the opposition lawmakers so that that's
why the law was like
pretty quickly um passed and imposed in
hong kong
and that they fear that there would be
another like push factors for
many um not only protesters but also
residents
to leave the city much much sooner
and yes that is the concern from them
and also for the ordinary citizens they
fear that um
they may not have another chance to
leave the city because of the blockage
and but the other hand the government
dismissed such fears as nonsense
and saying that the law only aims at
like tackling the um the uh the backlog
of the asylum applications and the
abuses of such system
and it has nothing to do with the
erosion of the
tribal rights you mentioned the
pro-democracy protest movement
how specifically will this attack this
law affect them
well as you've mentioned that hong kong
is now facing a great wave of
immigration we are talking about uh over
a hundred thousand people um like of net
flow
leaving the city since the
implementation of the national security
law last june that is the data from the
government
and this number uh keeps growing day by
day
so a lot of people leave the city
because of the concerns and also
the titan group of beijing so um this uh
although the new law will not be the
most important
um like uh drive of immigration but that
would be an additional push factor
for such um protesters who fear
prosecution and also
um like immigrants who are most of them
are highly educated families to leave
the city
earlier than planned okay dw
correspondent phoebe kong
in hong kong thank you for bringing us
up to speed